in this video we're going to think about
what it means to subtract vectors
especially in the context of what we
talked about as the parallelogram rule
so let's say we want to start with
vector a and from that we want to
subtract vector b and we have vectors a
and b depicted here what do you think
this is going to be what do you think is
going to be the resulting vector pause
this video and think about that
all right now the key thing to realize
is a minus b is the same thing
as vector a
plus
the negative of
vector b
now what is the negative of vector b
look like well that's going to be a
vector that has the exact same magnitude
as vector b but just in the opposite
direction
for example this vector right over here
would be the vector negative b
now we just have to think about what is
vector a plus the vector negative b well
there's two ways of thinking about that
i could put the tails of both of them at
the same starting point might as well do
the origin so let me draw negative b
over here so we know the vector negative
b
looks like
that so one way that you are probably
familiar is you have vector a and then
what you do is you take a copy or you
can think of shifting vector b so it's
tail starts at the head of vector a and
if you did that it would look like
this
it would look like this this is also the
vector
negative b and then the sum of vector a
and negative b vector negative b is
going to be going from the tail of
vector a to the head of vector negative
b
so this would be the result
right over here which you could view as
the sum of a plus negative b or the
difference of vectors a and b or vector
a minus vector b now if we want to think
about it in terms of the parallelogram
rule we could take another copy of
vector a
and put it so that its tail is at the
head of this negative b
and then we would get it right over here
and we are forming the parallelogram and
then the resulting vector is the
diagonal of the parallelogram and this
just helps us appreciate that we could
start with negative b and then add
vector a to that or we could start with
vector a and then add negative b to that
but either way you get this white vector
right over here which we can view as the
vector a minus
vector b and we're done